[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and people call me miss
marvel because when a woman shows up in
my room she'll find pictures of herself
everywhere what
so ms marvel has now wrapped up and it
arguably has one of the most important
endings to a disney plush show ever in
the final few scenes we get a big hint
towards the x-men and also what could be
happening in the marvels now originally
kamala wasn't inhuman but they changed
that up now to make her a mutant some
inhuman fans might find this upsetting
but let's be honest we all kinda wanted
this anyway you see though the inhumans
debuted in the 60s they weren't really
given a push until the northeast and
this had a lot to do with fox owning the
rights to the x-men marvel realized that
they were basically pushing a line in
their comics with the mutants that was
promoting a rival studio so they slowly
dialed things back this was discussed in
an interview with chris claremont back
in 2016 and he told bleeding cool that
the movie rights were a big reason why
the inhumans overtook the x-men in terms
of focus claremont stated why would we
go out of our way to promote a title
that will benefit a rival corporation's
films when we could take that same
energy and enthusiasm and focus and dude
for our own properties hence the rise of
the inhumans as the new equivalent of
the mutants so characters like ms marvel
were pushed as inhumans and slowly they
took precedent over them in the comics
marvel even introduced a rule that
stated no more mutants could be created
in the comics so that fox didn't have
any other characters haven't seen
anything this petty since paramount said
henry cavill couldn't shave his mustache
for the justice league reshoots and this
is why we pretty much only ever saw the
x-men movies with a core cast of
characters pretty much all of the new
mutant type characters were turned into
inhumans instead of x-men and agents of
shield ended up adapting them across
instead however disney did end up buying
fox and thus they got the rights back
which is why they've started pushing the
x-men once more we of course had
professor x showing up in multiverse of
madness x-men 97 is gonna be released
soon and kamala is now a mutant this
does somewhat mirror the comics as in
those she did believe she was one for a
bit before she eventually realized that
she was actually an inhuman now what
this means for her future we don't
really know but we do get this nice
little music sting of the x-men theme
tune
like a mutation
better show up in the movies that if
that gets played over the top of the
marvel studios logo i will lose my sh
[Music]
anyway as of now kamala is the first
mutant that we know about in the 616 but
i doubt that she's actually the first we
know from the multiverse of madness that
other universes exist out there that
have their own mutants and i think that
some might already be in the mcu now a
while back i dropped a theory time video
about how i think they're already
amongst the characters in the 616 it's
just that no one is aware of the x-men
this is because professor x might have
done something similar the memory spell
from noe home using his telepathy
through cerebro he could have
potentially reached out across the
entire world and have ended up wiping
people's memories so that the knowledge
of mutants no longer existed this would
save them from the persecution and hate
that has been a strong focus in the
comics this is something that i'd love
to see explored in x-men 97 and
potentially that could even work as a
prequel to the mcu that showcases how
mutants have always been in the 616.
however they might totally disregard
that and potentially we could have
kamala used as a way to discover other
mutants bruno has the ability to
diagnose them and together the pair
might work together to inert the rest of
them anow she's the first and in the
comics we have some that go as far back
as ancient egyptian times namely
apocalypse perhaps they've been lying
low and kamala could end up going to
charles xavier's school where she could
discover more of them after doctor
strange met him in the 838 he could
potentially look for him in the 616
which would open up the doors to his
school and a lot more i'd love to see
kamala even become a student of the
x-men once she gets back from the events
of the marvels as carol tends to be
off-world a lot of the time so she'd
need training while she's back home
she's also too cool little easter eggs
in this moment from nakia
get in losers we're getting shawarma i
love you the first is a reference to
mean girls and the last one is a
reference to the shawarma scene from the
avengers huge shout outs to ryan arie
for spotting that one
see i can't be nice you thought i was
going to say something bad there but i'd
like you to be nice as well and just hit
that thumbs up button much appreciated
now speaking of captain marvel we get
her popping up at the end of the series
in the post-credits scene this happens
when we catch kamala lying on her bed in
her costume the bangle starts to vibrate
and she then stands up kamala then
seemingly warps and in her place appears
captain marvel who busts through her
cupboard door leaving a carol sized hole
hey wouldn't mine wouldn't mind getting
brie larson back to my bedroom mate i
say one for the last one for the last
thought
anyway crap jokes aside there's been two
theories about what's going on here the
first one is that kamala has transformed
into carol due to her gaining
shape-shifting abilities i think this is
wrong personally but it does have ties
to the comics in the book no normal
which this episode is titled after we
see terrigen mist roll into jersey
whilst kamala is walking home from a
party she's encased like an inhuman and
then she bursts out of this looking like
captain marvel in the comics kamala's
powers were different and she could
alter her body to change any part of it
because of her ability to change herself
on a molecular level she could also
alter her appearance and look like
anyone she wanted to however i think
because of the reaction here that this
isn't the case carol looks around the
room and she takes in the posters which
she seems shocked by if this was kamala
then she wouldn't need to look around
the room like this because she already
lives there and knows what it is
therefore i think what's more likely is
that she swapped places with carol now
this all ties to the [ __ ] bands in the
comics these ancient creative acts
allowed people to swap places between
the negative zone and reality in the
source material the original captain
marvel wore them along with his earth
counterpart rick jones marvel as he was
known would be stuck in the negative
zone but when rick jones put the bangles
together he would swap places with him
rick would go there instead whilst
marvel worked on earth now imagine
another captain marvel aka shazam but
instead of the transformation they just
changed places shazam in the comics did
have a period where he actually swapped
out with billy but that's been changed
up and recently you don't care now how
this happened we don't know but the key
could lie with chongqi remember early on
in the series we watched as the bangle
was discovered in one of the temples of
the ten rings this clearly links it to
that organization but it's also likely
connected to the rings themselves now at
the end of chongqi we watched as he and
katie met with wong bruce banner and
also carol danvers they studied the
rings and it is possible that carol flew
off in the galaxy attempting to track
down the source of the beacon she then
might have come across the other bangal
touched it and then activated the one
kamala has and made them swap with each
other this would then hurdle her across
the universe and it would also explain
why she seems kind of shocked but almost
like she knows what's going on i think
that she might have triggered the bangle
by accident when looking over it and
potentially she was warned something
like this could happen but she did it
anyway this would lead nicely from the
events of chiang chi into miss marvel
and it would line up with the 10 ring
symbol that we saw earlier in the season
and the rings might also be part of the
bangle technology and they themselves
could be the opposite to it i always
thought it was weird that they changed
up kamala's powers from the comics but
tying it in with all that makes sense as
to why these choices were made when we
could have potentially been searching
for other artifacts like this so it
makes sense that he'd set up a temple
around it too this is all purely
speculation at the moment but i do think
at the very least they swap places just
like how they did in the comics still
though there's gonna be a lot of fan
theories that come from this so
obviously i'd love to hear what you
think below now i actually also want to
apologize for a mistake on the last
video i said the texts used in the
titles were urdu and hindu but as many
of you pointed out it should have been
hindi i actually had hindi in the script
but whether it was just saying urdu
before it or whatever i got it wrong i
really should have caught it in the edit
and i wasn't trying to disrespect to be
ignorant towards the languages it was
just a case of misspeaking again really
apologize for that and i'll try to do my
best to make sure that it doesn't happen
again hope you forgive me and if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
full episode which will be linked on
screen right now some great easter eggs
in it that we talked about so hopefully
i see you over there right after this
without the way thanks for sticking
through the video i've been poor i'll
see you next time take care peace